at just 13 years old coumay norwood is a
business veteran that's because she
opened her shop when she was just eight
years old and joining us now to talk
about tofu teas is its owner and founder
khumei norwood thank you so much for
joining us kumai
you know a lot of adults have trouble
keeping a business open for a year or
five years but here you've done it
you're just 13. what is the secret to
your success
um really it's just like
my parents helping me out and just
having fun with it
how did you come up with this idea five
years ago when you were eight um well
the design that started my business it's
why are people so sensitive and
it was miswritten and i found it when i
was eight years old
and then we just put it on a t-shirt and
people just started buying them and it
just grew into business yeah and this is
if we can show this this pillow i think
has the actual handwriting this is when
you were six you wrote this yeah and
your your question was
why are people so sensitive even though
i'm really sensitive myself yeah i have
no idea why i wrote that but you've spun
it into something with a cause too
because we're going to talk about some
of your great merchandise here but all
of it is focused on helping people to
think yeah and causing people to think
about how to make the world a bit better
how did you come up with that and why is
that important to you um well really
at a young age i was taught about
different social
issues
yeah that were happening around the
world
and basically i just wanted a way to
express how i feel about those
and
show that people can also express them
at the same time i love it and it's
working because now you have your own
store downtown right tell people where
they can find you um well i'm on fremont
and 10th street it's in a place called
ferguson's downtown
um yeah and i have a shop in there i
love it so let's talk about some of your
t-shirts and some of the merchandise you
have here and all of them have different
things written on them that do cause you
to think what are some of your favorites
um well one of my favorites is i love
unicorn slime inequality that was one of
my older designs
yeah that's it right there
and it was a few things that i used to
like and
yeah i'm trying to show this one where
are we on three yeah
that's great and then another one of my
favorites and probably the most popular
is racism is trash right here i like
that yeah
that is great and so you not only have
t-shirts t-shirts is your number one
selling item right but you also have
here examples of pillows and hats and
buttons yeah
where did
the drive come from at eight years old
did you say i'm going to open a store
no actually i started at this place
called market in the alley and basically
it's a whole market filled with small
businesses and i just popped up there
it was their first or the second market
in the alley that they had and i just
took my stuff there
um yeah and then it just helped me build
confidence with my business and tofutees
how'd you come up with a name
it's really funny actually i just really
like tofu and then at the time i was
just selling t-shirts so i just put them
together so people can go to tofu teas
downtown fremont and 10th street right
i congratulate you i know your parents
and everyone in your family must be so
proud of everything you're doing so well
thank you and i can't wait to see it
burgeon into a bigger and bigger
business over the coming years
thank you gourmet thank you so much for
joining us go check out tofutees
downtown rocky